so the question is when is the best time to take
vitamin d what you have to realize is vitamin d
is a fat soluble vitamin what does that mean it
means that you're going to have better absorption
like between 30 and 50 better absorption if
you take it with fat now there are vitamin
d supplements that already contain fat within
the supplement itself i'll put a link down below
of one that i recommend but if you're going to
take vitamin d as a supplement without the fat
consume your vitamin d with a meal but make sure
there's some fat avocado maybe some type of meat
that has saturated fat olive oil mct oil nuts
dairy egg any of the fats because you're going
to increase your absorption by 30 to 50 percent
more now there's one more point i want to talk
about if you have a sleeping problem you may want
to try taking your vitamin d right before bed and
here's why vitamin d can help increase your
non-rem sleep that's the deep delta wave sleep
that occurs in the first half of sleep vitamin
d receptors are located in the master clock that
controls the circadian rhythms it's called the
super chasmatic nuclei a very interesting word
it has receptors for vitamin d so there's a
huge connection between vitamin d deficiency
and sleep problems also there's
vitamin d receptors in your brain stem
which also have a lot to do with your sleep cycles
and on top of that and i just did a video on this
vitamin d can help reduce your cortisol levels
your stress levels so you may want to try taking
vitamin d right before you go to bed to see
if that might help you now for most people if
you're taking vitamin d right before bed you're
going to do fine you're going to sleep better
a small percentage of people it may wake them up
they might need to take it earlier in the day but
if you have a sleep problem you may want to
just try it there's a couple other vitamins
that you can also add if you have a sleeping
problem vitamin b5 which has a lot to do with
lowering cortisol folate which is a b vitamin that
can also help your sleep cycles and vitamin b1
especially if you have a lot of worry and you're
thinking at night and you just can't turn it off
so if you have a sleeping problem try taking
vitamin d right before you go to bed and comment
down below and let me know how it worked hey
before you go if you're benefiting from any of
my content i would love to hear about your success
story please share it in the link down below